what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some very good news
about Jeremy Renner our Hawkeye sadly
and tragically on New Year's Day Jeremy
Renner while trying to help out his
neighbors was hit by his own snowplow
the report says that his upper torso was
actually crushed by a snow-cat vehicle
which is a very large vehicle to get hit
by in true Hero Fashion he was helping
out his family and his neighbors around
him by helping clear out some snow and
then he pulled over on the side of the
road to help a car that was stuck in
which he got out of a snow cat and it
began to move he tried to jump back in
it to stop it but it hit him this put
him in the ER in a very critical State
and he actually had to have two
surgeries everybody was super worried
but eventually he came out and posted on
Instagram stating that he was kind of
okay basically he was going to live but
he remained in critical but stable
condition well like I said today we have
some awesome news he has officially
discharged charged out of the hospital
and he is back home and he confirmed
this himself by posting on Twitter
actually right now he is the star of the
Paramount plus series mayor of Kingstown
and the official Twitter account for
this series posted something on Twitter
in which Jeremy Renner replied outside
my brain fog in recovery I was very
excited to watch episode 201 with my
family at home so this is incredibly
great news the doctors would not have
discharged him if they didn't think that
he was going to be okay and that he was
well enough to be outside of the
hospital on his own not hooked up to any
type of machines not getting any type of
medicine from the hospital themselves
although I'm sure he's on a lot of
medication right now still recovering
but the good news is he is home which
means he's in good enough condition to
wear we kind of don't have to worry too
much anymore of course we're still going
to worry about him but the great news is
it looks like everything's going to be
just fine with our Hawkeye so this is
great news we're keeping him in our
thoughts and our minds and our prayers
go ahead and leave some positive
comments for Jeremy me Runner Down Below
in the comment section and of course if
we hear anything new we'll be sure to do
an update we'll catch you all in the
next video as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf